let me bring out a snack that another
snack that i'm sure you guys have
probably never seen or heard of before
okay i'm glad that uh i'm glad that i
actually bought them
what is that ah i did buy these one time
yeah i thought they were chocolate
yeah they weren't chocolate most people
don't look at this and go oh look
it's actual pieces of turd i thought it
was chocolate i was so hyped to dig in
what is it basically it is black sugar
particles but when you black sugar
particles sure like really salami on
this
it's like fried black sugar right i'm
pretty sure that sounds like a physics
type but when you pull it out it
straight up just looks like a turd okay
i don't know what this is it's a very
fancy name for a turtle yeah that is a
turtle brian griffin's poop
there you go what is this you know what
that looks you know what this looks like
this looks like a turd that like a
pomeranian would do
like a small dog
you know what that ain't bad yeah right
it just tastes like
sugar with air it just tastes like a
crisp sugar yeah
it's basically just deep fried sugar
yeah i honestly don't really like that
really
that wasn't really tasty it's it's a
black sugar is kind of a hit or miss
with a lot of people
i mean i mean like okay so the thing is
i couldn't eat a whole packet of these
yeah i
i chomp on one of these i'm like that
was nice am i am i getting a craving to
do
should go for one more nope one's enough
for me
so wait what what is this in japanese
again this is called
what a [ __ ] name is black sugar
karinto is like the name of the actual
snack how unhealthy is it to just eat
the entire thing
what's the calories on that one calories
uh
698. how many grams for the whole bag
130 [ __ ]
how many times how much sugar is in that
[ __ ] i mean you're just eating pure
sugar yeah
37 grams wait that's way less than i
expected no
i mean it just feels like you're eating
fried sugar there's actually more carbs
in this there's 81
grams of carbs holy what
okay oh there's seven grams of uh
of protein in this stuff oh oh great
after a workout
perfect for after a workout where's the
protein coming from
where the [ __ ] is the protein coming
from no idea we're literally making
protein out thin air here
japan be doing that did they just put
like a bit of a little bit of protein
powder in it just
pretty much just like balance it out
we're gonna make this healthy somehow
exactly shall we bag full of things now
these are more like i guess sweets or
kind of
all right should we just shall we just
dump the rest on the table and see what
we got
all right look at look at all that
that's this holy [ __ ] i've
seen it let's see what santa wants us
way more than i think you guys do is
that
i do have so many sweets there all right
should i just start with the stuff that
looks interesting okay first of all
one of my favorite japanese snacks it's
got to be top it's top tier for me this
is
here senbei in general though oh yeah
in general not mochi but senbei in
general there's a senbei store not too
far from mars yeah i go
like every week
oh [ __ ] senbei is so good if you don't
know it's like a rice cracker
but it's basically like it doesn't feel
too heavy
and you can have like one or two and you
feel like really satisfied it's not too
bad for you either yeah i mean it's just
like it feels like it feels like a
crisp but just lighter and for some
reason it's more filling
than a single crisp oh yeah an entire
packet of senbei is like so this is
yeah oh my god whoa this is a funky
texture to it
okay is it soft yeah it's like a soft
cookie a soft baked senbei
ooh okay is it chewy it looks chewy oh
my god what is that
okay oh this is yeah so mochi senbei is
kind of in the same
so there's different types there's hard
senbei and then the soft so
there's hard zembo and then this rock
[ __ ] solid sound
there are some senbei where i've had
there was one the there was like it was
like yuzu pepper or something
and i was like oh that sounds amazing so
i order it right and i [ __ ] like
break my teeth i swear biting on this
[ __ ]
what is it like a jawbreaker honestly
there's like there's the perfect
hardness which is just cracks
immediately
it's like a rice cake right that's what
you want and then some of them it just
feels like you're biting into a stomach
that's really
this like if this if this was a cookie i
would think this is the perfect
there's actually there's actually one
more level above this called nude which
literally means wet [ __ ]
and it's like actually like wet but they
but they make it for old people who
can't like
break it down that's wholesome
what the [ __ ] whoa that's weird
yeah so mochi rice is actually different
from regular rice mochi rice is a lot
softer and a lot more like squishier so
you get something like this yeah it's a
little
it's a little whack ain't it oh that's
so bizarre yeah
i don't like it okay so you know what it
is
it's it's moist to explain what to
explain
laughing what's funny marlene to to
explain what i just experienced
so as we said this this has the perfect
texture for like a good cookie and
like my my experience has told me that
this is gonna i'm gonna bite into this
and it's gonna taste sweet
and what i tasted was a salted cracker
with a moist cookie texture
it isn't bad though i i'd eat it like i
wouldn't i wouldn't search for it but
i'd eat it
that that was that texture and taste
just doesn't belong together i don't
know some something about that whatever
you've kind of been conditioned right
yeah maybe it's not because i i
i i taste it and it tastes good and i
feel the texture and the texture feels
good but together
it just does not synergize at all it's
like anti-umami
man
this is my favorite type of sandbag yeah
jesus i just want to show how hard it is
we actually have the smaller kabuki
these ones i i buy these i like these
but when you have like four or five you
start to feel sick
oh yeah they're so like uh what's the
what's the word to describe
these are really good yeah so there it's
like how would you describe the texture
it's
cavernous it's like a it's like the
thing from fantastic fours
i don't know what it is that's like
amazing for like one or two bites but
really like sickly after like three yeah
you know what i mean
i i don't know man i could i could just
maybe it's just me it's probably just
yeah yeah yeah it's not bad though i
mean
these are my favorite types of sandbags
i think so this tastes exactly the same
as what we just had but this is the
texture i imagine that tastes having
it's
it's just like it's a nice salty cracker
just with a bit more air
in between or like it's it's it's fatter
than the cracker
but it's lighter than the cracker it's
kind of like eating
like cotton foam just like flavored
right so
what are we having from yours okay so
i've never actually seen this before
but i know this brand baby you start
army uh so basically
it's yeah it is so basically baby style
ramen is like the kind of
really uh what's the what it's like the
dried out ramen oh is it the instant
ramen
it's like the instant ramen looking
things but it's in a snack form and i
guess this is like the mozzarella
flavor right
oh my god that looks next level i need
to try this here you go you know
i hate this is my first concern but this
just cannot be even remotely healthy
right
of course it's not healthy it's
literally fried in some ramen noodles
it's fine i kind of like it okay
i don't know if you did the same thing
but as a child
sometimes you would sometimes i would
take instant ramen like harden instant
ramen
and just kind of like smash it up into
little pieces put like put like the
seasoning on it and just eat it like it
was like yeah
we had a brand of that it's called mammy
noodles like that would actually sell
packets of that [ __ ]
this is the best are you in prison what
do you want to do because it tastes
[ __ ] great
[ __ ] off you know mammy noodles right i
did the same thing
yeah right yeah have you never had like
the ramen
seasoning or like the instagram
seasoning no it tastes [ __ ] bomb it's
like
it's like putting the seasonings like
msg yeah it's like pure empty
yeah like it's as as a kid i was told to
never do that because it's unhealthy as
[ __ ] but
it's this i guess someone someone grows
a product
this literally tastes like childhood
yeah it tastes like every asian
childhood
it's got a little spice to it too which
is nice okay okay
it's so good on salad you mean croutons
they're not crucial yeah they're not
crude
they do look like they do kind of
what is that yeah that's mustard what is
this i
don't actually like it yeah let's crack
it it's from lawson's i don't know what
it is
our intern just bought it
what's that i'll just that just looks
like a potato
it's just shipped i guess the [ __ ]
oh my god that was a kick to it oh
wow oh my god that is a cake okay
i'm not a fan oh yeah you don't like
condoms
this is like condiments in a stone it
tastes like mayo and mustard in a
like a crisp that's so weird i actually
kind of [ __ ] with it it's [ __ ]
horrible
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you're
like condiments
condiments are meant to be you know i
meant to enhance food
they're not meant to be the food i
literally just ate i literally just ate
hardened mustard and mayo
i actually kind of like that yeah it's
actually kind of good
it has a really strong like mustard kick
to it so i'll pick another one because i
have too many
um what looks interesting that's we
literally have these in the uk yeah yeah
that's that's fine what are those what's
this
uh like the biscuits
oh yeah the creams the custard creams
custard cream biscuits
um this is cognac
chip seaweed and salt konjac
yeah low in calories natural lawsons
okay
okay should we give it a shot oh yeah
yeah konyaku does have zero calories so
well wow wow gamers let's give it a shot
go on go ahead
thank you very much go ahead look at
that
that looks healthy i don't know if
that's a little comment i don't know
i can literally see through it that's
how you know how healthy it is okay
don't say
anything
that's the most inoffensive thing ever
yeah that tastes like
air with an off with like a hint of
seaweed i try these chickens the moment
like
moisture hits it it just dissolves and
disappears that was literally like
eating nothing
you know what it was it was a rice
crispy if it been scaled up in size but
not with like the added ingredients
you needed to scale it up it's literally
just take going to photoshop
have you seen that video on the internet
where someone manages to like deep fry
water
yes someone managed to deep fry water
right like a like
like a packet of water that's what i
imagine that tastes like how would you
do that